- Hey everyone.
Welcome into Market Takes.
You know what?
I know you could have been
anywhere in the world
but you're here with me,
and I appreciate that.
I am Dion Rabouin, reporter
for the Wall Street Journal.
Listen, it is a short week
but we are still getting lots
of data out this week.
I'm gonna tell you the three
most important things you need
to look out for this week,
and they are three reports
that are all coming out on Thursday.
We'll be right here doing
Market Takes Thursday at noon.
We usually do it at 10:00 AM,
so make sure you adjust
your sleep cycle and all that
so you catch us here on
Market Takes Thursday at noon.
But we're gonna be talking through,
today, the Existing Home Sales Report
that comes out on Thursday,
the Leading Economic Indicators Report
and the Initial Jobless Claims Report
that also comes out on Thursday.
Thursday is gonna be a big day,
I'm gonna tell you why.
So first things first,
let's talk about that
Existing Home Sales Report.
That is the main report
on the housing market
because most homes that are sold
in the United States are existing homes,
as in already built homes,
not new homes.
One that you buy that was built
in the 50s, 60s, 70s, 80s, etc, etc.
That's the big one,
and that shows us what's happening
with about 80% of the housing market.
But what we have seen recently is
some data on those new home sales
that suggest that maybe that's part
of the market is heating up,
and the existing home sales
market could be heating
up as well.
So far this week, we have already gotten
the NAHB Housing Market Index,
as well the Home...
New Home Starts, or Housing Starts.
That data came out on Monday.
And just this morning on Tuesday,
we have seen a big pickup.
First things first,
I wanna throw up here on your screen
the NAHB Housing Market Index.
Now, this data shows a very clear trend
and this is what we're seeing
across the new homes part
of the housing market.
Very clearly, home sales
declining, declining, declining,
and that's really market sentiment.
That's how folks feel about
the housing market.
When we talk about the
Existing Home Sales Report...
Or sorry, when we talk about
the Housing Market Report,
that's a survey of
about 900 home builders.
A reading above 50 indicates
a favorable outlook on home sales,
below 50 indicates a negative outlook.
And as you see up there on your screen,
we had fallen well below 50,
hitting almost that 30 level,
at the end of last year.
And then starting this year,
you see month over month,
every month picking up
and rising higher.
And so, just last month we got...
Or I'm sorry, yeah,
just last month we got a reading
of 55 on that outlook.
And so, that just
illustrating very clearly
that confidence, optimism,
the outlook on the housing market is
really picking up.
Those home builders are going out,
building more homes,
putting more inventory out there.
That should provide more supply.
And as we know, there's a lot of demand
and supply is rising,
that could do something
to bring down houses...
Or to bring down prices, excuse me,
in the overall housing market.
But again, we have not
really seen that same pickup,
and we need to see a decline
in the number of existing homes sold
to bring down those prices.
So a very clear trend when we see
what's going on with
the Home Builder Index,
with new home sales.
New home sales actually were the highest
since May of 2022.
We also saw the NAHB Housing Index,
that was the highest since July of 2022.
And the new home sales...
I'm sorry, housing starts was
the highest since May of 2022.
And we saw those new home sales rise
in a big way to the highest
since May of 2022 as well.
So housing starts,
which is the forward-looking indicator,
"how many homes were actually built?
"Housing construction, or how many
"new residential permits
started on being built?"
That was the highest since May of 2022.
The NAHB Housing Market Index,
showing home builder
confidence, sentiment, all that,
highest since July of 2022.
And the new home sales was the highest
since May of 2022,
with 683,000 units sold.
This really just showing us
that the housing market is booming
and coming back in a big way
on the new home side.
But as I said earlier,
existing home sales are what really matter
and we will get that report on Thursday.
And we're gonna find out if
the existing home sales
trend has continued
along with the new home sales trend.
So let's throw up here a chart
on your screen of the existing home sales
and what we've seen from that report.
As you see there,
new home sales have been declining
in that same way over the past year
into the end of the year.
And then, in January we got a big pickup
in the number of new...
In the number of existing
home sales sold, excuse me,
and that showed...
And that has actually been declining.
So if we see that trend continue,
that could put downward pressure on prices
and that could be a good thing
for the housing market.
Now, that chart up there on your screen,
just illustrating that we have seen
a turn down in existing home sales,
but still above the level and the trend
that we saw coming into
the end of last year.
Why does that matter
for the everyday average person?
Well, if home sales
prices are coming down,
that means that rents can come down
because those landlords that are buying
those houses and renting 'em out
to people aren't gonna be paying as much,
they're not gonna need to make
as much in rent to justify that purchase.
That's gonna allow them
to give some flexibility
to their tenants,
going with the overall economy.
But if those prices keep rising,
keep getting higher,
as we've seen with the
new home sales market,
that could put upward
pressure on inflation,
push inflation back up.
That gets to the Fed,
that gets to asset prices,
all of those things,
so that would be an overall negative
for the market.
So you're gonna wanna watch
that Existing Home Sales Report
that we get out on Thursday.
We're expecting to see
another decline in May,
just like we saw in previous months,
in April and in March before that.
But if we don't get that
and we get an unexpected pickup,
that could be bad news for the market
so you'll wanna watch out for that.
Next thing I wanna talk about is
the leading index...
Or the Leading Economic Indicators Index.
I wanna put a chart up here on your screen
to show you what we're seeing
from that report as well.
Now, this report, much less bullish.
There's really not a lot to it.
As you see there,
when the index starts falling below...
When the Index of Leading
Economic Indicators falls
below zero, we tend to have recessions.
You see that when it holds
below that consistently,
recessions tend to follow it.
And we saw it in 2008,
we saw it in 2020,
and it looks like right now
we are seeing that same trend,
and actually a more clear
and long-term trend
in that Leading Economic
Indicators Report.
So that chart is illustrating just
the clear trend that we are in right now
with those numbers.
May expected to show another decline,
actually a bigger decline,
than what we saw in April.
In April, the Leading Economic
Indicators Report declined
for the 13th straight month.
So we've seen more than a year
of continued decline on that report,
and actually it is a
steeper rate of decline
for the previous six months
than the six months before that.
So really just showing right now,
things are not good.
The LEI is the conference forward index.
It usually is a good predictor of GDP.
GDP is how we measure recession.
So when it goes down,
generally we tend to be
in recessionary territory.
Includes things like the S&P 500,
the treasury yield curve, credit indexes,
but also a lot of things
like manufacturing data, business surveys,
like the ISM and Purchasing
Managers Indexes.
So we know the S&P is really picked up,
we know that stocks have
been booming lately,
that could push that index back
into positive territory.
Definitely will be something
you wanna look out for.
The Atlanta Fed's GDP now
reports showing expectations
for the Fed...
Or for the GDP to come in positive,
almost right at two percent.
The Federal Reserve is expecting GDP
to recover this year
and stay outta that negative territory,
so we shall see.
This will be a good report
that you'll wanna watch on Thursday
about what happens.
Last thing we wanna talk about is
those initial jobless claims number.
Let's put this chart up here
on your screen of initial jobless claims
and look at that.
You see there,
we are seeing a clear trend of picking up.
But most importantly,
as you see the far right of your screen,
those last two numbers have been
the highest we've seen since January 2022,
so well above the trend.
And we don't know if those are outliers.
Are those something like what we saw
a few weeks ago, or a couple months ago,
with Massachusetts having some fraud
in its claims?
Are those, though, the start of a trend?
And if they are, could
we be seeing big pickups
in unemployment and layoffs?
And could that be a sign that
the job market is starting to weaken,
the labor market is starting to weaken?
So keep your eyes on on this report,
the US Initial Jobless Claims.
That's how many people are applying
for unemployment insurance
and things like that
because they've been laid off.
This chart illustrating that we have seen
a very clear pickup over
the last two weeks in that data.
And we will send...
We will look and continue to see
if that trend continues.
So we're gonna break all that down here
on Thursday at noon on Market Takes.
I hope you'll be with us,
I hope you'll be with me,
as you are today.
Thank you so much.
I'm Dion Rabouin, reporter
with the Wall Street Journal,
and we will see you right back here,
Thursday at noon, on Market Takes.
See you next time.